[Musique]
ces images de l'émeute de victoriaville
en 2012 ont profondément indigné le
public
c'est le moment où le sergent daniel
gauvreau et battus par des manifestants
écoutons la version officielle des faits
selon les informations que nous avons
obtenues
c'est que ce policier là aurait
justement était en train d'aider un
autre citoyen citoyens le policier
agressé a récemment témoigné lors de la
cause d'un autre collègue en déontologie
c'est la première fois qu'on entend sa
version et c'est bien différent de la
version officielle de la police on est
en plus confié étudiants 2000 personnes
se donnent rendez-vous et victoriaville
pour dénoncer le gouvernement libéral la
manifestation dégénère rapidement mais
quand cet incident survient la
manifestation est presque terminé la
poule 2 quand même discours si vous
entendez le sergent daniel gauvreau
lors de son témoignage c'est lui qui a
été battue en se dispersant certains
manifestants s'en prennent à des
véhicules de la sûreté stationné tout
près
[Applaudissements]
le sergent gauvreau décide d'intervenir
sans aucun équipement de protection mise
à part sa veste pare-balles j'en ai vu
un qui me vue s'apprête à lancer la rush
sur l'autobus me vu qu'il a laissé
tomber la roche puis par sa course et
que je porte à consacrer il agrippe le
suspect et l'entraînent au sol une
mauvaise stratégie
selon cet ex policier monde est le seul
boxeur une zone de support après
manifester je veux pas le lâcher mais là
tu perd toute notion ton environnement
juste que tu es sur le focus
manifestants à la première chose que tu
paies ta moan et en cercles its 23 400
go de doigts et c'est ce qui se produit
le geste du policier attire tout de
suite l'attention après tout se passe
très vite la poule moins d'un mètre de
la nôtre même ils ont sont approchés
rapidement un peu otages avec le monde
pour lui venir en aide son collègue le
lieutenant patrick côté sauf dans un
camion et fonçant la mairie et j'ai une
roche qui me rappelle le derrière de la
taille puis à ce moment l'aube à
yopougon le lieu d'un côté ne parvient
pas excepté son collègue de l'année il
repart avec cinq amis et j'arrange dans
la foule en espérant sortir de l'eau
sans croiser personne parce que
concrètement je vois rien en droit et
c'est là que le sergent rob vos et
frapper violemment les tirs de gaz
lacrymogène lui permet de s'échapper
il reconnaît qu'en voulant faire cette
arrestation il n'a pas agi selon les
règles de l'art c'était un erreur de
maintenance gens qui font ça j'y vais
lui le fait que
dispersion de la police de nom on voyait
ces gens là qui lançaient des roches qui
c'était mon travail tant qu'à moi de
démarrer notre site et la mort éditions
gp en somalie le sergent gauvreau s'en
tire avec des ecchymoses et des
courbatures
suite à cet incident il a même complété
son quart de travail ce soir là les il
ya un blessé grave le l'étudiant maxence
balade a reçu un projectile au visage le
perdu un oeil
il est persuadé d'avoir été atteint par
un tir des policiers pendant l'incident
le de attiré 10 balles de plastique dix
balles en 40 secondes
même si des gaz pour ce cru à la vue du
tir air et malgré le risque de tirer en
rafale dans une foule city ont été jugés
conformes ne blessé poursuit la sûreté
du québec
le procès reste à venir lors de la
manifestation de victoriaville six
policiers ont tiré un total de trente
trois balles de plastique ces hommes
font partie d'un arsenal militaire de
plus en plus utilisé par les policiers
mais qui remise en question partout dans
le monde
les balles qui sont en plastique très
durs peuvent atteindre plus de 260 km à
ce type d'armes a été utilisé lors de
plusieurs manifestations étudiantes en
[Applaudissements]
selon la plus récente étude
une personne sur six qui se rend à
l'hôpital après avoir été frappé par une
balle de plastique aura des séquelles
permanentes une sur 37 va mourir à
victoriaville on ne connaît pas le
nombre exact de personnes atteintes mais
en plus de maxence balade au moins deux
autres étudiantes été gravement blessé
par une balle de plastique
l'étudiante de binic la liberté a reçu
un projectile au visage et le souffert
d'une double fracture de la mâchoire
alexandre allard a eu une fracture du
crâne et une double commotion cérébrale
il aurait pu mourir les deux ont
poursuivi le gouvernement et ont réglé
hors cour
malgré qu'elle puisse être mortelle
sésames sont toujours permise au canada
en contrôle de foule les policiers en
seront d'ailleurs équipé lors du sommet
du g7 dans charlevoix
[Musique]